we're now going to do a few examples to
actually show you why the trig functions
are actually useful so let's get started
with a problem
let's say i have this right triangle
let me
that's my right triangle
there's the right angle
and let's say i know that the measure of
this angle
is
pi
over 4
radians and i'll just write rad for
short
if the if the measure of this angle is
pi over 4 radians and i also know that
this side of the triangle
this side right here
is
10
square roots
of two
so i know this side of the triangle
i know this angle which is pi over four
radians and now the question is what is
this side of the triangle
i'm going to highlight that in let me
make it in
in orange
so let's figure out what we know and
what we need to figure out
we know the angle pi over 4 radians and
actually it turns out if you were to
convert that to degrees it'd be 45
degrees
and we know what what side is this this
is the hypotenuse of the triangle right
and what are we trying to figure out
we're trying to figure out the
hypotenuse the adjacent
side to the angle or the opposite side
of the ankle
well this is the hypotenuse we already
know that this is the opposite side
excuse me
this is
this is the opposite side and this
yellow side is the adjacent side right
it's just adjacent to this angle
so
we know the angle
we know the hypotenuse and we want to
figure out the adjacent side so let me
ask you a question what trig function
deals with the adjacent side
and the hypotenuse right because we have
the adjacent sides what we want to
figure out and we know the hypotenuse
well let's write down our mnemonic just
in case you forgot it
so which one uses adjacent and
hypotenuse
right it's it's k
and ka the c is for what
the c is for cosine
cosine of a angle let's just call it any
angle is equal to the adjacent
of the hypotenuse
so let's use this information to try to
solve for this
orange side or this yellow side
so we know that cosine
of pi over 4 radians so let's say cosine
of pi over 4
must equal
this adjacent side right here let's just
call that a a for adjacent
the adjacent side
divided by the hypotenuse the hypotenuse
is this side and in the problem we were
given that it's ten square roots of two
ten
square roots of two
so we can solve for a by multiplying
both sides of this equation by 10 square
roots of 2 and we will get
because right if we just multiply times
10 square root of 2
these cancel out and you get a 10 square
root of 2 here
so you get a
is equal to
ten
square roots of two
times the cosine
of pi
over four
now you're probably saying sal
this does not look too simple and i
don't know how
big the cosine of pi over 4 is what do i
do
well no one has the the the trig
functions or the values of the trig
functions memorized there's a couple of
ways to do it either i could give you
what the cosine of pi over 4 is and
that's sometimes given in a problem or
you can make sure that your calculator
is set to radians and you could just
type in pi over pi divided by 4 which is
roughly 0.79 and then press the cosine
button you can you finally know what
it's good for and you'll get a value or
and this is kind of the old school way
of doing it there are trig tables where
you could look up what cosine of pi over
4 is in a table since i don't have any
of uh that at my disposal right now i'll
just tell you what the cosine of pi over
4 is the cosine of pi over 4 is square
root of 2 over 2.
so
area so a not area a which is the
adjacent side a for adjacent is equal to
10
square roots of 2
times square root of 2 over 2. remember
to get the square root of 2 over 2 you
might be a little confused like how did
sal get that all i said is the cosine of
pi over 4 is square root of 2 over 2 and
that's not something that well actually
this one you might know offhand because
it's a 45 degree angle but this isn't
something that people memorize this is
something you would look up or it's
given in the problem or you'd use a
calculator for
and in a calculator of course wouldn't
give you square root of 2 over 2 would
give you
a decimal number that's not obviously
square root of 2 over 2. but anyway i
told you that the cosine of pi over 4 is
square root of 2 over 2. and so if we
multiply what's the square root of 2
over 2 what's the what's the square root
of 2 times square root of 2 it's 2.
so that's two and then that
that cancels with that two and so
everything cancels except for the ten so
the adjacent side is equal to ten
let's do another one
let me
let me
delete this
and give me one second i'm actually this
is one of the few modules that i'm not
generating the problems on the fly
because i need to make sure that i
actually have the the trig function
values before i do the problem
so let's say i have a another right
triangle
another right i should probably should
have deleted that last one so let's say
this is my right triangle
how much time do i have four minutes
left that should be enough
so this is my right triangle
and i know the angle
um
let's call this
well
i know this angle right here
is .54
radians
and i also know
that this side right here
is three units long
and i want to figure out this side
so
what do i know
well this side is what side relative to
the angle
it's the opposite side right because the
angle is here we go opposite the angle
so this is the opposite side
and what's this side is this the
adjacent side or is it the hypotenuse
well this is the hypotenuse right the
long side and it's opposite the right
angle so this is the adjacent side
so what trig function uses opposite and
adjacent
let's write down sohcahtoa again
right toe uses opposite and adjacent oh
it reminds me of that well anyway uh so
t for tangent right toa
so tangent
is equal to opposite
over adjacent
so let's use that so let's take the
tangent of 0.54 radians so the tangent
of 0.54
will equal the side opposite to it so
that's
3 right the opposite side is 3 over the
adjacent side well once again the
adjacent side is what we don't know so
we have to solve for a
so if we multiply both sides by a we get
a
tan
of 0.54 and we could do that because we
know
it's not zero
equals three or a
is equal to
3 divided by the tangent
of 0.54
so once again
i i don't have memorized what the
tangent of 0.5
uh 4 is
but i will
tell you what it is because
you also don't have it memorized or you
could use a calculator to figure out if
you had a radian function
the tangent of 0.54
is equal to
let me make sure i have this right oh
right the tangent of 0.54 is
three-fifths
so then a
is equal to three
over
three over five
right the adjacent side because and once
again how did i get this three-fifths
well i just told you or you could use a
calculator to know that the tangent of
0.54 is three-fifths
and of course i'm using numbers that
work out well just so that the fractions
all cancel but so we know the adjacent
side is equal to when you divide by a
fraction it's like multiplying by the
numerator
multiplying by the inverse
so times five over three
so the adjacent side is equal to five
there there you go so let's just think
about what i always do i think about
what i have what sides i have and what
side i want to solve for in this case it
was the opposite side i had and i want
to solve for the adjacent side and i
said what trig function involves those
two sides the opposite and the adjacent
i wrote down sohcahtoa i said oh toa
opposite and adjacent that's tan so i
took the tan of the angle
and then i said the tan of the angle is
equal to the opposite side divided by
the adjacent side that's right here and
then i just solved for the adjacent side
and of course i used a calculator or i
told you what the tangent of 0.54 is
i think i'll do a couple more of these
problems in the next module but i'm out
of time for now have fun